das jahrhundertbauwerk mit credit suisse
abb die mobiliar und coop
[Musik]
die kommt eine ganze reihe weiterer
brauchen die familie aus italien
zugezogen
die arbeitsbedingungen waren ganz
offensichtlich katastrophal das ganze
unternehmen
[Musik]
kein anderer tunnel in dieser zeit
forderte so viele tote und verletzte
durch steht
was ist im gotthard ist dass das
weltwunder ist in der technik der
kanzlei konzipiert sind
man musste kehrt tunnel bauen um den
höhenunterschied zu überwinden
das war eine pionierleistung und europa
der bau des gotthardtunnels ein wunder
ein wunder der technik und der schweizer
ingenieurskunst
im ersten jahr sind dann schon million
übte tun
der tunnel ist der grund weshalb man
heute vom gotthard mythos spricht
[Musik]
ursprünglich war der gotthardpass wild
und nur beschwerlich mit mauleseln
passierbar der historiker oder ratio
martinetti zeigt uns weshalb
[Musik]
hier sind wir genau in der bio timo
schlucht einer schlüsselstelle dieser
straße die man auch völker weg nannte
erst an dieser brücke war es möglich mit
kutschen zu reisen
zuvor hatte man alles auf erden und
mauleseln transportieren müssen und von
hier gelangt man zum da zu lande
das ist der erste durchgang dieser
schlucht die vorher fast unpassierbar
war
in der bilden scheinen schluss über die
freundin fluten daraus wurde im grünen
bogen eine steinbrücke gewalt die
teufelsbrücke
[Musik]
und so wird der chor tat zur
nord-süd-verbindung zuerst mit der
postkutsche
[Musik]
sie sehen ihre preise verbindungslinien
zwischen hamburg und jena zwischen paris
und dreh dich sondern und trinken
der schnittpunkt all diese linien liegt
auf dem gotthard kein wunder dass dieser
schätzung europas von den vier ströme
und flüsse ihren ausgang nehmen rhein
rhone und pc dieses gegen ende des
achtzehnten jahrhunderts bei den
menschen als höchster berg professor
françois walter ist spezialist für
schweizer geschichte
wir treffen ihn im museum des kantons
uri für mich ist es ein sehr emotionaler
moment hier neben diesem symbol der
schweiz zu stehen es ist ein symbol wie
die armbrust von wilhelm tell oder
später die lokomotive des gotthards und
diese kutsche stellt in
anführungszeichen schon eine sehr
schnelle transport mit oder darauf
dann läutet dieser mann eine neue ära
ein
[Musik]
unser kleines land wird mit diesem
durchstich in die zukunft katapultiert
der initiant des gotthards alfred escher
war ein politiker der vorausschauend
erkannte dass die schweiz im begriff war
eine absolut fundamentaler technische
revolution zu verpassen
beteiligt haben sich italien deutschland
und die schweiz
und zwar sowohl auf öffentlicher als
auch auf privater basis
die finanzierung erfolgte also auf
internationaler europäischer ebene
denn viele länder hatten interesse an
dieser nord-süd-verbindung es waren
deutschland und italien die aus
politischen gründen für die
gotthardlinie votiert hatten
für deutschland stellte sie eine
schnelle verbindung durch die alpen da
ohne das territorium des erzfeindes
frankreich zu berühren und für die
italiener war es die gleiche situation
sie wollten die alten durchqueren aber
auf keinen fall abhängig sein von der
infrastruktur des
österreichisch-ungarischen reiches
konrad conny er hat die geschichte des
tunnelbaus ausführlich erforscht
deutschland 20 millionen und dann in die
schweiz aber nicht der bund sondern
föderalismus die kantone vor dem
gotthard vereinigung im 15
und nur durch sparen und zentralbahn die
an
auslands millionen zahlt der rest ist
eine rote ausgabe von aktien und
obligationen ein drittel obligationen
das ist im januar 18 27 sind denn die
zeichnet das ist ein riesiger
ausstellung sie und zum teil 50 fach
überzeichnet es ist ein riesiges problem
es war überhaupt kein problem die rund
100 millionen an der browser zu zeichnen
man hätte sogar vielmehr zeichnen können
denn viele leute wollten aktien der
gotthardbahn gesellschaft kaufen
die unerfahrene genfer louis favre setzt
sich überraschend gegen an italienischen
tunnel spezialisten durch dann kommt
farbe und sagt ich baue schneller und
weniger teuer deshalb hat die
gesellschaft ihm den auftrag gegeben
[Musik]
die historikerin eva schumacher hat
untersucht was für folgen das hatte
waidhofen sco dass er das gar nicht was
das sind 111
er hatte erst wenige tunnel gebaut besaß
kaum erfahrung aber in diesem
jahrhundert projekt sei eine art
selbstverwirklichung seine große
leistung war einerseits sich in ein
absolut verrücktes unternehmen zu
stürzen
ein unternehmen dass niemand für
realisierbar
zudem wollte er diesen auftrag unbedingt
erhalten der betrieb gar dumping
die experten sagten man brauche für den
bau neun jahre und farbe kommt und sagt
ich mache es in acht jahren
[Musik]
er werde ein großes gewaltiges kilian t
elsasser hat sich mit der technik des
tunnelbaus beschäftigt definiert dass
man damit erreicht und die vermassung
rose vor tricks üben gotthard web.de
matt vom ton offenbar kober wobei die an
den schuhen schwärmte scharrer
ingenieure und kilometer aus und lebt
ihr unsichtbares triangulation netz
doch wie genau sind die messungen werden
die tunnelbauer überhaupt
aufeinandertreffen zum 30
die bilder des tunnelbaus liegen im
archiv der stiftung sbb historic mit der
damals modernen fototechnik lassen
fahrer und escher den bau dokumentieren
fahrer und seine ingenieure setzen beim
bau auf neue methoden zum beispiel auf
solche loks angetrieben durch
komprimierte luft
[Musik]
überreste der druckluftanlage existieren
noch heute oberhalb des portals ball
gekommen
[Musik]
das wasser gebraucht hat um druckluft
hat steht für den bau von gotthard
tunnel das druckluft einer
schlagbohrmaschine betriebe also
durchaus bohrer 1 entsprang netz
gebraucht für lokomotiven großes
verfahren oder schlagbohrmaschine
repariert oder sinne zu bringen
und drittens die luft ist auch der
komprimiert wurde dem vorschlag von
maschine und dem nachlass der luft
braucht
wir müssen schon anders aus dem barocken
stadt den kohle wagen setzen wir riesige
druckerpatronen ab sie lockt die luft
aus den patronen drückt auf die
kontraktion die räder an und alles was
hinten raus kommt es einem wirklich noch
zum 8
ich muss weiter nach airolo max
bei mir lassen
zur zeit des gotthard tunnels gibt es
noch keine filmaufnahmen doch 1909 filmt
eine kippe wie der lötschberg tunnel
gebaut wird
auch hier sind die am gotthard
entwickelten druckluft loks im einsatz
der große vorteil sie verschmutzen die
ohnehin knappe dünne luft nicht mit
rauch
[Musik]
zurück zum gotthard im spätherbst 1872
beginnt fahre mit dem bau
[Musik]
technik auf die technik auf mechanische
bohrmaschinen auf lokomotiven mit
druckluft die die arbeit erleichtern
sollten
er setzte auch auf die damit
viel zu
dynamik der große fortschritt
hochwirksam aber gleichzeitig hoch
gefährlich dass das placebo
dieser sprengstoff der noch wenig
bekannt und sehr gefährlich in der
handhabung wurde bei tiefen temperaturen
instabil und forderte viele tote
die todesursachen bahn vor allem dynamit
explosion dann unfälle mit den
einfahrenden zügen und stein statt
doch der vortrieb kommt schon bald zum
stillstand
trotz moderner technik
man sagt die bohrer brechen ab schwer
verletzt sie schaffen im moment gerade
zwei meter am tag wenn es so weitergeht
sitzen hier noch in 20 jahren
natürlich wird es immer wieder
verzögerungen geben investitionen von
uns allen hielt sind in der frage zum
schluss unterschrieben dass auf jedem
tag noch auf jahre verspätet vor an
krebs muss zahlen
das ist ja wahnsinnig ist um resultate
auf jetzt sind also 200 franken pro tag
nach einem halben jahr 2000 franken kurs
und nach einem jahr verliert 8 millionen
franken hat sich ein bisschen irgendwie
zusammen mit kollegen aus ganz innere
sogenannten kommanditgesellschaft und er
präsidiert hat die acht millionen
kaution bei und nach einer verspätung
ist im vertrag so fest konnte sie dort
die ganze kautionen gesellschaftslehre
tüte betrieb 120 millionen franken für
zum völligen ruin natürlich von denen
kann man die türen um 5 auf und die
freiheit einfach den auftrag unbedingt
wählen und hat sich im prinzip bis die
tiere aber vollkommen unsinnig sich
machen sie druck vor dem fahrer vortrag
heute werden die sagen es gab viel
stress auf der baustelle weil der bau zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
fertiggestellt sein musste der zeitdruck
hat sicherlich unfälle verursacht die es
sonst nicht gegeben hätte
derzeit ringt man musste schnell
arbeiten
deshalb gab es keine
sicherheitsmaßnahmen seit tagen wird
kein meter mehr geburt was passiert
[Musik]
mit immer mehr arbeitern hofft fahre die
verspätung aufholen zu können
aus den bergdörfern göschenen und airolo
werden städte
grüße als plötzlich saphir und über
2.000 wenn die tunnelarbeiten natürlich
zum teil auf marine brach zum teil frau
danach eine hat natürlich plötzlich neue
handel bei und und schuhe machen bei dem
durchaus vorhanden ist die tusler und
kofferraum fotolia mexiko gar nicht
deutsch britisches kultur gemischtes sie
eigentlich auch und eben das alles da
fängst du mich nicht groß breite konrad
coni hat herausgefunden woher die
tunnelarbeiter stammten
das gibt das archiv mit den opel bezirks
dieser liste mit den opfern
und das sind knapp 500 tunnelarbeiter
kritische und dem staat damit sollte der
name und herkunft meistens in einer
schrift um eine burka lassen und zum
teil an der tech welt aber am schluss
eine der noch knapp wolf und daniel
wirklich auch umgesetzt und dann jeden
einzelnen so bin ich dann quasi einfach
mit dem datenmaterial zu einer schätzung
und die schweiz es sieht so aus dass 41
prozent brutale hosen mit
[Musik]
die cd heißt grassi netto der hat zwei
positionen 50 euro im jahr akzeptieren
hatte glichen sie 52 0 gewonnen und es
sind mitarbeiter von freenet um im
gotthard sie also drin also vereinfacht
kann man sagen sind pure aus der
italienischen provinz aus diesen
regionen hatten zuvor schon viele
arbeiter im frische tunnel gearbeitet
vorher auch im brenner tunnel
sie kannten sich also aus mit dieser art
von arbeit hier im tessin hingegen
fehlte diese tradition
man hatte hier nur einige kleinere
tunnel gebaut heute würden wir sagen das
know how fehlt
[Musik]
die italiener die in gott haus
arbeiteten hatten zu hause keine arbeit
sie kamen um hier arbeit zufrieden die
schweizer die die heimat verließen
machten dies weil sie sich durch die
emigration ein besseres leben erhoffen
das war das phänomen der auswanderung
deshalb finden sich so wenige tessiner
auf der baustelle
sie arbeiteten er in der landwirtschaft
melkt die kühe auf den alpen und viele
wanderten zu dieser zeit aus nach
kalifornien zb aber um sich dort fest
niederzulassen
um wirklich mit der familie laut leben
zu können und wenn möglich
landwirtschaft zu betreiben
beim gotthard hingegen ist das ganz
anders das ist eine temporäre eine
risikoreiche arbeit
man wusste nicht wie lange sie andauern
wird
die leute aus der gemeinde aus dem dorf
haben begonnen zu spekulieren und den
arbeitern zimmer zu vermieten
sie fürchten die arbeiter buchstäblich
in häusern ein
[Musik]
es waren bedingungen könnte man sagen
ähnlich wie im wilden westen während des
goldrausches
nach wwf ist von 310 bald 800 fremde
hier vieles hat sich geändert
was hier passiert wenn die menschen noch
in hundert jahren profitieren alle welt
blickt auf das tor die bevölkerung und
damit dank des sehr groß sind oft
ehefrau mit chrysler schwester
alleinreisende frau wo sie da noch
größer sind als wäscherin zum teil heiße
luft als spezialagent über 20 spezial-
laden
der unsittlichkeit das ist glaub sie und
wie den frauen erinnern hätte das denn
oft ist also dass man geschafft hat aber
die aufnahme von trinkgeld klappt es ja
auch um das zubrot sieht dass meine
befindlichkeit und dies verursachte auch
ungehalten unter der ortsbevölkerung
denn sie hat mit personen zu tun die
zwar arbeiteten aber die auch ein wenig
freizeit hatten
es gab also gaststätten das glücksspiel
trotzdem viele einheimische profitieren
[Applaus]
die bevölkerung hat wirklich zu
spekulieren begonnen hat versucht das
maximum zu verdienen indem sie minimale
leistungen zu extrem hohen preisen
offeriert das ist wie viel kostet im
monat zahlen voraus 12 frankenhausen
noch ich bin einfach angst im ruderclub
four letter word können aber auch keine
träne als experiment aus einer der
hütten sich alles zusammenfügt
angeschrieben und es ist hier leider
klappt gar keine maschinen über nacht
das alte bett das ist auch ein
metallteil taxis und unhaltbare zustand
[Musik]
550 aussteller halbe million heißt wenn
wir die zahlen zurück
unterwegs in florenz kommt auch
überhaupt gezahlt würden lampard ist
also drei discs lampenöl vermisse
zusatzzahl eine operation für die
gesellschaft hat im übrigen 40 franken
im jahr verdient stellen sie sich vor
die franken zum tragen wie jetzt für
musik im jahres ist gigantisch ist um
40,6 millionen dh die lohnsteuer oder
hütten von der lohnsteuer die gibt es
natürlich aber ich freue mich natürlich
viel viel größer so wenig lohn und
furchtbare arbeitsbedingungen
die mitte form durchbruch vom
rechtsstaat ist es überdies grad
finanzminister
dennoch hat sie den frost und zwar viel
ruß machtlos die mannschaft muss man
auch berücksichtigen dass die tiere
ihren teil beitrugen
besonders die pferde und maulesel und
das bei 30 bis 35 grad im innern des
tunnels
hier
trolley zudem diene laune und dennis hat
dynamik aus das ist eine unglaubliche
gestank und es ist sind katastrophale
verhältnisse
genial
es stinkt denn für mich als nächstes
land gestorben des trinkens wo man nicht
nachhaltig verunreinigen und zum teil
bis zu 20 stunden hier die frische
tageslicht kommt das ist natürlich grau
auf das gesundheitswesen
es ist viel zu viel platz 2000 hatten
auch zu sehr viele umbau geführt wenn
die rollwagen meter breite bahn sieht
ein sieg trennt und die verarbeiter und
die musiker gaben die römer über einen
drittel von denen hunde bringen
unfalltote sind einfach vor den
rollwagen schlicht und einfach
überfahren
man riskierte sein leben oder zumindest
riskierte man allerhand zu verlieren
oder einen arm oder noch schlimmer die
augen und gesagt wir werden nie wissen
wie viele unfälle es gab wie vielen
arbeitern ein bein zerschmettert wurde
wie viele einen arm verloren haben und
wie viele in folge dynamits erblinden
blick
ab
denn wir mit dynamit gesprengt und
druckwellen angestaubter der mann unter
einmal die staublunge sind auch giftige
osten
720 juli auf 10 7
spontan schleichen organisiert schnell
ist groß in diesem moment bekam es mit
der angst zu tun und er bat die
regierung schon daumen und forst rechter
zu schicken um den streik zu
unterdrücken
mit dem titel - dann wird aber gefordert
dass das einsatz gibt dass man die
schweiz muss vertrieb
in al tur verbrauchen und und denner und
wechselte wieder bürger werden
konstituiert dass es im männer-team
gesammelt wurden
das sind erfahren genug dass sie mit den
gefahren und das kommando
wichtig sind natürlich habe trug sich im
steigflug china gesichert und der
deutschen börse hat ohne dass das
kommando kitty hat man plötzlich auf
eine süße die richtige polizisten und
hilfspolizisten angefangen schüsse
und dann sind dann einfach für arbeiter
verschossen wurde
der streik ist abgewendet
ja aber nur mit einem schlag gegen die
demokratische gesinnung alle friedlichen
verhandlungen sind gescheitert
es galt den tunnelbau zu sichern nicht
um jeden preis
ich fordere eine untersuchung der
arbeitsbedingungen auf den tu den
baustellen durch die alt genossenschaft
die große drahtzieher polit ist für eine
ganze gruppe panzer rissen bundesrat
welt xi an diesem tunnel klebt jetzt
blut meine heirat der kontakt zum skw
hat der kontakt zu der die schirn zu den
italiener k
und dann haben wir ein oberst fuhr mit
der untersuchungszeit ständig sie und
oberschule vor dem fantasy
[Musik]
herr coni fand einem bericht der nie
publiziert wurde
der als geheim klassifiziert war die
dritte rang in diesem bericht war klar
geschrieben dass das unternehmen die
polizei aufgefordert hatte den streik zu
unterbinden
natürlich hat anja haupt systematisch
ein anders ausgelegt und bieten
plötzlich auf einen brief von ixia das
ist wiederholt unterschied kommt wieder
auch sehr vertraulich und dann bin ich
von kein bericht vor dem höhepunkt vom
immer historisch aber natürlich sie und
mit dem kein break zu wiederholt das
eigene ist arbeiter völlig rechtlos
segelt während er in größe und die säge
sägen arbeiter see gebracht wurde von
anderen arbeiter energie das gewiss
behörde gibt es grüßt politik ist
gehörig tdx energie der täter verhaftet
sondern übergab ziel aus ist einfacher
betritt sperren und billiger und die
tägliche 10 euro tunnelarbeiter vom
niederländer ist uns im 3g genannt los
ist nicht so dass die arbeiter einfach
alles nur die live gesehen
ich zähle natürlich kann da verbracht
und geschwiegen
irgendeine gemacht wie historiker müssen
diesen kommissar diesem oberst hans holt
dankbar sein denn sein bericht
ermöglicht uns die bedingungen am
gotthard im nachhinein zu rekonstruieren
nicht nur verbrechen bleiben ungesühnt
plötzlich ruft auch eine geheimnisvolle
krankheit bis vor kurzem kerngesunde
arbeiter seien
[Musik]
sie hatten eine geheimnisvolle krankheit
die sich in blutarmut äußerte aber auch
in symptomen wie husten katar durch
walter kurtz verschiedene arten von
schmerzen die man nicht genau zuordnen
konnte die arbeiter wurden sehr schwach
sie konnten nicht mehr arbeiten und
deshalb schickte man sie nach hause auch
hier wissen wir nicht wie viele weil die
rotation airolo wie auch in göschenen
sehr hoch war
man schätzt dass 20.000 bis 25.000
personen sich auf diesen baustellen
abgewechselt haben wir zufällig wurde in
turin ein italienischer arbeiter
hospitalisiert der an seltsamen leiden
mit er starb dort es war ein berühmter
arzt namens bellotto der diese krankheit
im darm des arbeiters entdeckte der fand
rund 1500 firma die dessen blut sorgte
der italienische arzt der den parasiten
fand wurde später mit einem ehrendoktor
der universität manchester ausgezeichnet
denn seine arbeit ermöglichte es bessere
sanitäre bedingungen in den tunnel
arbeitsplätzen zu entwickeln
beim simplon bau zum beispiel gab es
keinen einzigen fall dieser krankheit
der bundesrat gibt widerwillig eine
untersuchung in auftrag
er sieht den arzt sonderegger nach
göschenen
und dass da eine vom sonntag oder über
die haut geworden über das andreas thoma
die originale problem
die große frage woher dieser parasit
stammt denn normalerweise entwickelte er
sich nicht auf dieser höhe
wir sind doch hier auf über 1000 meter
über meer
er benötigt eine recht hohe temperatur
nun im tunnel betrug die temperatur 35
grad und das feuchte klima war günstig
für sein wachstum
die italienischen ärzte konnten
nachweisen dass der parasit aus den
fäkalien der arbeiter stammten mehr die
weniger und es zwischen regierung also
eigentlich wurde die öffentlichkeit
jetzt wirkt das tor ja irgendwie das
alles nicht so publik wird und dass ein
frank otto bauer und der donau
rechtzeitig fertig stellen der bundesrat
hat nur eins sicher und es ähnlich sieht
das die ganze strecke und hatte mit
arthur möglichst schnell fertig erreicht
hat ihn nicht interessiert
doch am 18 juli 1879 stirbt louis farben
der bau ist noch nicht fertiggestellt
[Musik]
er hatte wenn ich so sagen darf das
glück vorher zu sterben er musste all
die miseren die ganzen probleme die die
verspätungen verursachten all die
strafgelder schadenersatzforderungen und
so weiter nicht mehr erleben
er ist als held in seinem tunnel
gestorben und das hat zur
legendenbildung beigetragen
er hat seine gesundheit in diesem tunnel
verloren aufgrund all dieser konflikte
mit der unternehmung mit den ingenieuren
mit den arbeitern
er war wirklich ein unternehmer wie in
die schweiz liegt deshalb diese
mythische aura
wir lieben menschen die aus einfachsten
verhältnissen stammen die keine
intellektuellen sind nicht oder nicht
lange studiert haben und denen es
trotzdem gelingt innovative lösungen
vorzuschlagen und meisterwerke zu bauen
kapital ist
hallo
wir sind durch
[Musik]
anschluss an die tour um mit der ganzen
reich der mitte also der horizontale
drei zentimeter brüchigen 45 zentimeter
wahnsinnige leistung für die mit
einfachen methoden besser machen
sie sind durch seine berechnungen waren
richtig
[Musik]
das hat verkörpert das heißt forschenden
sensation sie am schluss wurden die
beiden chöre sich dann zum showdown
kommt mit 20 februar 1808 die legende
sagt fahrers bild sei beim durchschlag
als erstes durchgereicht worden
dies ist ein ganz außerordentliches
gewaltiges ereignis das in der
geschichte der zentraleuropäischen
staaten einen tiefen einschnitt
hinterlässt die scheidewand ist gefallen
welche die nationen trennte die länder
sind einander mehr glück
[Musik]
erste haus in zwei millionen toten frau
das heißt hat eine explosion bei
natürlich für den personentransport
[Musik]
die linie wurde ursprünglich einspurig
gebaut blieb aber nicht lange so sehr
bald wurde das zweite gleis gebaut
denn eine internationale verbindung kann
nicht eingleisig funktionieren
der tunnel hatte enormen erfolg die
schwärmerei für diese strecke zog
touristen an und als in der ganzen welt
das bild einer technologischen schweiz
einer schweiz des fortschritts und der
modernität zu verbreiten
[Musik]
der antrieb erfolgt noch bis zum ersten
weltkrieg mittels dampf die
dampflokomotiven hatten die oberhand
aber wegen des krieges wurde die
elektrifizierung forciert denn die kohle
kam aus deutschland und die schweiz
wollte auf diesem gebiet unabhängig
werden also beschleunigte man
unmittelbar nach dem ersten weltkrieg
den übergang von der kohle zu
elektrizität 1922 war praktisch die
ganze linie elektrifiziert war hinter
nicht reich und lange doch die mühen und
kämpfe haben sich gelohnt
waren es doch die elektrifizierten
bundesbahnen wie in schwerer zeit
kräftig dazu beigetragen haben die
unabhängigkeit und freiheit unseres
vaterlandes zu erhalten
so hat sich unser volk in den
schweizerischen bundesbahnen ein
werkzeug geschaffen das nicht nur ihm
gehört sondern ihm auch mit allen
mitteln dient
[Musik]
es war die schweizer industrie welche
die schweren lokomotiven konstruierte
wie zum beispiel das krokodil dass sie
auch ein mythisches objekt darstellt als
güterlok für die gotthard züge
die überdacht
[Musik]
die gotthard scheiteltunnel
jahrzehntelang die nord-süd-verbindung
und jetzt wird sie abgelöst durch den
basistunnel der längste eisenbahntunnel
der welt hohe geschwindigkeit
moderne technik aber auch hohe kosten
veranschlagt aber das normal der
vorkommen veranschlagt mit 77 aktive 300
millionen kostet und es wird dieser
große projekt locker bin ja eine
transaktion zu viel der natur weiter
durch parlamenten oder volksabstimmungen
also gehen wir einfach zum teil haben
und dann können wir ihn halten ist nach
salamitaktik das ist jetzt auch noch wie
türen und doch noch die türen und auch
noch schön aber verschiedene davon
paradoxerweise kostet fahrers tunnel
weniger als budgetiert
doch als gesellschaft mehr gewissen sind
absurd riesen und gewinn gemacht für 4,7
millionen mit den berufen gotha tunnel
während alle anderen eigentlich ruiniert
sie sind statt aber mehr mitarbeiter
sind dafür auf stunden unternehmen für
alle finalisten verlust schafft sie für
die private gesellschaft ist
[Musik]
erst 50 jahre nach der tunneleröffnung
wird ein denkmal enthüllt
zum gedenken jena die beim bau starben
[Musik]
es steht beim südportal in airolo
absolut
friedrich wie politisch kein linker was
die bautätigkeit im kanton l betreffen
es ist so kapitalisten verdient stadt
eingeschrieben und arbeiten gestorbenen
krank wurde
die wirte sind sicher über 200 auf der
baustelle verunglückt
aber seid natürlich all die leute krank
wird es ihrem hohen gesang sie eine
staublunge
[Musik]
das heißt die zahl der toten und
verletzten war sehr hoch
wir werden aber nie exakt wissen wie
viele menschen starben weil wie schon
gesagt die rotation in airolo wie auch
in göschenen sehr hoch
man schätzt dass 20.000 bis 25.000
personen sich auf diesen baustellen
abgewechselt haben viele kehrten wenn
sie krank wurden nach italien zurück
direkt ich denke dass der goldabbau in
einer gewissen weise den sozialstaat
vorbereitet hat denn dann auch beginnt
man versicherungen zur integration
[Musik]
im jahre 1877 hat das schweizer volk das
erste fabriken gesetz angenommen man
sicher haben die situation am gotthard
und das entsprechende internationale
echo die abstimmung beeinflusst das
gesetz hat dazu beigetragen die
situation der arbeiter zu verbessern
[Musik]
eine art von arbeitsschutz wurde
eingeführt
und ich denke dass der gotthardtunnel
dafür ein schlüssel ereignis war er half
den sozialen schutz der arbeit den
versicherungsschutz den sozialstaat
einzuführen
[Musik]
es war der übergang in die moderne heute
mehr als 100 jahre später eröffnen sich
mit dem gotthard basistunnel neue
entwicklungschancen
[Musik]
das jahrhundertbauwerk mit credit suisse
abb die mobiliar und co